what else buddy of mine trying to get me
to invest with him in the zoo that's
crazy but I guess I've been lightly
considering it he got the read on our
zoo down in Sinaloa I guess down in Mako
so Sinaloa the officially the estado
libre he's so but I know so that I don't
they seen how long okay kind of chatty
there on Wikipedia about it but yeah my
buddy got a read on a zoo that went
under down there so I don't know what to
think about that you know I got a caught
up in some bad investments when I was
young we did a pyramid scheme and and
and it made me fight my peers actually
so I guess I don't know if that's what a
pyramid scheme is supposed to do but me
and my peers [ __ ] lost a bunch of
money and then we ended up fighting I'd
love to know that actually if anybody
ever done a pyramid scheme and got lost
and what the fallout was from it locally
if he'd hit the hotline with that I'm
curious about that nine eight five six
six four nine five zero through nine
five zero three running through the
house with a pickle on your mouth
ain't no misbehaving that [ __ ] is wicked
brah
that's that hot beat so anyway we'll see
man I don't know if a zoo is really
gonna beat my buddy said that animals
are real hot in Mexico right now so but
I don't know that just so we'll see man
if that's something that I can get more
information about because y'all did that
we did glitter when I was young they
some dude came through you know you know
I'm not sure who it was but rolled
through town and got everybody into a
glitter mining back when people thought
glitter was a um
precious or semi-precious stone and they
popped and they [ __ ] got us you know
so people you know I'm felling into some
you know I've fallen in the dark
financial waters dude how his financial
water is not a name of a honestly a
young urban gentleman bro that would be
the best name ever but yeah I don't know
if suing her but any malice is real
popular my buddy said down a Maiko so
we'll see but I don't know if getting
involved in a zoo down there is the best
overall use of of my earnings but it's a
cool down in the coolican coolican cooly
cooly akan province Culiacan see he said
this three point two one six million
down there people and that's as of this
year but who knows how many knows people
are hanging out staying there but but
yeah man you got to think that out of
three point two one six million people
you only need how many people out of zoo
every week to make it function and make
money
I bet probably two thousand people so if
you can't get two thousand people to go
to a new zoo in Mexico out of three
point
excuse me out of three point two one six
then
are you even a businessman that's one of
my big questions what's up James from
San Jose [ __ ] I was just listening to
your podcast now you're talking about
the zoo in the Kulik akan promised oh
yeah my buddy got that read down there
on that uh that Sinaloa Animal Sanctuary
baby uh yeah what do you know you have
any info don't know if you know but
that's where I'll chop those boys are
and they're going ham right now so I
don't know if that'd be the smartest
investment you just wanted to give you
the heads up I don't know if you've been
watching the news lately that [ __ ] is
going crazy brother gang gang
Gang Gang man no I didn't know that
thank you for that information that's
one thing I love about this this back
and forth we have here is the
information I receive so if El Chapo's
boys are out there but see that's when I
think people could use an animal the
most you know a couple people getting
murdered or whatever and you get to go
touch a soft animal you know and that's
like it's almost like when you touch the
back of a dam beautiful and when you
touch the back of a beautiful ape or a
beautiful you know a kitten or even one
of those little dogs that's in a
wheelchair or something there's nothing
more beautiful than that
then rubbing your hand it's almost like
sticking your hand right into Heaven's
ass you know like right in there just a
right into heaven when you touch the
back of an animal over the back oh you
need to touch the front of a of a you
know a soft seal or something or ostrich
or yeah or something you know at a
petting zoo you they let you touch a
damn [ __ ] lemur or something or check
its throat for a see if it's nozzles or
you know if I might have a cold or
whatever I mean that that can cure a lot
of people who I'm saying so the thing
the thing about the zoo that gets me is
could it be you know to your friends
just got beheaded you get to go look at
a couple lambs or whatever [ __ ] or
just being together you know because
it's not always about sex you know then
that could be something that could be
special but out you know it's crazy
because my boy and even gotten back to
me I mean he's down there getting
responded to like the past four messages
so we'll see man but I got a lot of
response about that people saying dude
don't do a zoo in Mexico well yeah easy
for you to say you don't have the
opportunity to do it dude I might uh
buddy - ask me about investing in a zoo
actually in Mexico in Sinaloa I've been
there
yeah oh man they don't have any issues
out there you should definitely do that
well some of its beachside I think if
you look it up I don't know I don't know
if the end of the b-side no a cartel
would be the main issues there that's
why they need people to come in and a
new desk hold up
you think you're opening a zoo and
sanella Mexico and you don't think got a
grease the palms the cartel there bro
you think you're bringing zebras and
you're bought the van these are you
think you don't have to grease the palms
of the underworld you think you're
bringing in a bearded lizard pass out
chapo and you don't have to grease the
[ __ ] balls daddy
got your goddamn I'm bro dude I look
it's not I don't know a buddy am I got a
read on an animal investor dude get a
read and open it somewhere close to us
man all invested its 140 800 to get in
bro can you give me any information
derek OGG of Luis is here but can help
him out Louis Wow dude he's racist right
told me you were yesterday
what are you Louise I [ __ ] called it
dude didn't call anything Sutter's
native a man okay but you kept calling
Mexican I did my respect to them and
just kept it very [ __ ] you man yeah
Latino yeah do you know whatever dare
yeah whatever dude it says but either
way here I'm from Mexico he knows it's a
bad idea open a penny he's from America
have some respect battle bro you open up
of fighting petting zoo they're either
you know saying he Petty's you you
[ __ ] it's a sanctuary for anomalous
will you give us some information Derek
it's apparently not safe to be there for
foreigners very risky and don't be out
at night the most words well they the
most risky but Americans can't go there
and your dumb ass don't open up on all
white people zoom it's a damning zoo zoo
it's not a knight say what this seems
like a [ __ ] cover-up for sex
trafficking that's what it sounds like
ooh my times it was a horrible idea
animals get frisky dude what do you want
otherwise these animals are gonna be
coming up here looking for her bro we
need to take care of these animals on
their home court hit up Whitney Cummings
if you have a giraffe send it over right
now air quality's bad today if the other
hippo let me know I'll bring my truck
I'll be at the corner of Highland and La
Cienega tonight taking all emus and
larger that's what her please no snakes
dude here's what I'm saying sinaloa
beautiful daytime you need is there any
images if you click on Sinaloa how about
this first thing that pops up showers in
a blaze of bullets no you're not open to
do their [ __ ] click on an image hey
you know you should do open open a
[ __ ] petting zoo in Syria right now
dude hey this isn't the spot hold on I
just burped I do want to open up
actually a a company like a cling-wrap
company in Syria calls Syrian wrap know
whatever dude well listen to this man
animals deserve love everywhere and I
think do it then 48 Hyundai you know and
I know it's expensive but to know that
animals are doing well there and hope
then one of the whole city's on fire
which one you live on right in the
middle
oh that's where they're looking I'll
repeat that down like that one oh it's
just a bunch of dead bodies that's a
bunch of dead bodies that were put in
the river yeah it's time oh there's snow
when the mix was most violent states but
you know what makes people relax and
calm down guinea pigs see I mean Molly's
anomalous oh look at that she put your
guns away man forget the drugs today
homes yeah I like lambs steel Vaughn's
camera over here bro yeah bro ooh look
the Rat King have a [ __ ] a porcupine
up here porcupine and the awesome man
well look man sorry I want to invest in
Mexico dude knows how it happens people
wanna invest in Mexico they get turned
down by a guy who's wearing the Eagles
jacket but doesn't want support
EGH Alice huh the eagle is a-- what
about the Oh
do I like my flamingo hey are there
eagles in Mexico Mexican Eagles look it
up Mexican eagle nope bald eagle
I would assume he's the America's logo
because of you can only get him here
Mexico unlike any brother found
throughout the world the bald eagles
found only only in North America you
[ __ ] get so goddamn red white and
blue only found in North America dude
that's their that's the Mexican eagle
right there no hold up it says the ball
don't hold up the bald eagle only found
in North America bald eagles are found
throughout most of the North America
from Alaska Canada how fantastic that
nobody seen that other part there we go
well Louisa's from Central America dude
yeah dude you kept calling Mexican I
thought he was here yesterday well he
led me to believe some things Oh a
Central America believe in ghosts
spirit day hablo pop eh yeah for mayor
white camera guy ghost amen
your mama and papa bleep up yep yeah
your mom does you don't know if his
mother does it cuz he's white don't pick
on him all right everybody deserves a
[ __ ] chance bro everybody dude yeah
man
so look man good luck with the petting
zoo in Mexico dude it's not for petting
dude and they need better PR for Sinaloa
man yeah yo Theo scary from Pennsylvania
what's up Gary oh hey Gary hey Gary
hey hey Gary hey Gary you know I thought
when I was young I thought my name was
Gary for a little while because somebody
lied to me but I told myself I forgot
that it was me that it told myself that
and that crazy let's hear more yeah uh
you know I just I'm listening to your
mother's podcast and uh some dudes call
El Chapo being down in the Sinaloa you
know no there was a Sinaloa cartel
oh yeah that's down there with that
animal sanctuary I was trying to get in
with and I haven't heard from that guy I
mean that's the only thing I'm not gonna
invest if I can't even get a text back
from the guy hope he's all right
homework and I have to agree with him
and I don't think this is a good
investment just are the last few weeks
old chapel son was kidnapped and his
whole cartel so try to sit the whole
city on fire you know obviously you're
not an investment or anything but I work
on my neck in estate you know well look
man I feel you thank you I want to say
that thank you very much the only thing
I'm thinking look if they're burning if
they're burning property you know what's
running out of the fire anomalies okay
penguins
Yaffe's burrows parrots Falcons perros
Gatos pescado
um I don't matter videos so I'm talking
about getting free ah
I'm taking off getting you know stocking
at my warehouse for free if they're
gonna burning it down you got to think
reverse psychology so now I'm gonna come
to an investment but um but I appreciate
a mallet ear a little bit more I mean to
shut you off there brother
I just want to see you this over and
that [ __ ] is on fire over yeah but fine
I mean here's the thing dude after fire
comes a lot of beauty think about the
Big Bang Theory think about that think
of
that song fire on the mountain you get a
mountain think about let's hear more
from your amount of ideas on it I think
you do better and it doesn't look really
good like people I'm not even trying to
they're not even trying to go outside
recently so just be careful what you do
there gang bruh muchas gracias Senor on
I do appreciate that it's very sweet
Evita call especially you know probably
having a little bit more of an Intel to
the to the deal yeah it's $4,500 to get
in on a zoo down there and here's the
tempting thing I've always wanted on the
zoo
though I don't think there's a man out
there that doesn't want to have a that
have a little bit of Tarzan and they're
nuts
you know you lift up my or meet us here
oh you know I got everybody's got that
thing that that beast in them I got that
beast infection and you know just
thinking about just being at night and
just having a unicorn outside or not a
unicorn us but having a you know a um
you know an exotic horse with nice hair
think about that
imagine a horse that's just [ __ ] in
cornrowed its whole body nobody's doing
that that's what we do with the Mexicans
ooh la zoológico they may go so I'm
saying 4500 to get in on a you know on a
Sinaloa and zoo
that's it sounds it doesn't sound like
much you know I'm saying you're talking
about some real serious animals you're
talking about a South American Eagle
think about that [ __ ] boy you know what
I'm saying dude he's gonna be bald he's
gonna had that deuce bro he's gonna have
[ __ ] one of his claws real sharp
touch
this saying man you're gonna have some
really exotic animals at that zoo you
gonna have a giraffe dude maybe in a um
no but he gots all kind of neck tats
think about that ms-13 ms 14 ms 15 ms 16
and all the way on through you know till
he graduated high school so there's just
the possibilities are endless on the
type of animals you could have in a
mexican zoo you have to think about it
all
I appreciate you though brother and
thank you man thanks for calling in it's
nice of you oh man here we go we had
another call that came in oh where oh
wait uh here we go yo bill truck
mississippi taxidermy buddy listen i'll
just start thinking about your little
zoo project What's Up Chuck do ya Chuck
man what's going on oh you're calling
about the zoo - Chuck sent me a whole
bunch of beautiful thing a meat elk and
everything elk
um [ __ ] I don't know what all's in there
dude I've had a couple pieces of it it
is tangy let's hear more thanks Chuck I
think it's a winner dude get that zoo
I've come out of the taxidermy Gator on
those animals you want me not to feed
them no more man people just come have
them nice I'll posed up listen I think
it's a winner I'm gonna go ahead and
order some materials get after you got
my number Oh
dude we don't have the funds for
materials yet man we still dealing with
the preliminary ordeals we're still
dealing with the first you know
potential war deals brother and you got
to make it through potential ordeals Bay
before you get into that secondary level
which is what you're trying to be at but
I don't that's not a bad idea maybe
taxidermy zoo and Matco like almost like
a Ripley's Believe It or Not but for
animals and dude some of the animals
could even have a gunshot or something
mental you know you see a [ __ ]
largemouth bass out there with two
[ __ ] slugs under its fan you're like
damn
there's more than one way to cook a fish
gang brother thanks for calling Chuck
man I miss you dog all texting good
afternoon and other times thanks for
watching that video you just saw I mean
it was okay but the next video you can
watch could be way better what if you
watch a video right now that changes
your life
well you could watch this one or watch
this one watch this one watch this one
watch this one